rất là lượng đã tích cực thực hiện như vụ tại chiến nghiệm trong thời tiết nặng
ôi những khục hiện nghiệm trong thành công đưa gió ngoài mẹ 2 thì thế đã nhân
nâng tổng số nạn nhân được tìm thấy lên còn số 2 mía ba
càng đỏ đoàn cũng bàn giá cho địa phương
lực lượng tại chỗ bởi điểm có nạn nhân có lại
cũng trong ai 1 thống bây, lối ngủ y tế có đoạn của hộ của nạn Việt Nam
đã khảm các thuốc cho bằng 2 lực người bảo đam hiệu qua
nhận được nhiều tình cảm và sự tì nhiễm của người dân nước sở tại
trong ngày hôm nay
đoạn tiếp tục cửa lực lượng cho ra thành nhiều muy
thực hiện như vụ tìm kiếm tại các thuốc nghĩa còn nạn nhân mắc kèt
phối hợp cho chế với lực lượng của các nước và người dân địa phương
rất tâm trạc đua với thời gian để tìm kiếm
đưa được nhiều hôm nước ở các nạn nhân của chạm đọc đất bể với thành nhân
đoạn Việt Nam tham ra khó phục hộ qua đọc đất tại vì thế này
rồi là gồm một trong hai mẹ 2 thành viên
đây là lần thứ 3, của đội nhân dân Việt Nam và công an nhân dân Việt Nam
cửa lực lượng phương tiét ra nước ngoài
thực hiện như vụ hỗ trợ những đạo giữ trở thành qua